en el corazón de esta zona árida se
encuentra el campamento de pugnar a un
punto de paso obligatorio para los
migrantes que llegan a la parte europea
de chipre con la esperanza de tener una
vida mejor
más de 1000 hombres mujeres y niños
quedan retenidos tras estas rejas cada
mes mientras presentan sus solicitudes
de asilo
el buró de servicios yo no
munir es de alepo en síria atravesó el
mediterráneo en una barca neumática y
desde hace 15 días vive en esta
construcción prefabricado
el nuestro puede ser abanico adelante en
eso ni se va a formar perfecto
todos llegaron a chipre en embarcaciones
ilegales
sé que las autoridades chipriotas están
bajo prisión porque están recibiendo
muchos refugiados he visto reportajes al
respecto pero todas las demás carreteras
están cerradas
munir y sus compañeros esperan que
pronto se les permita salir del
campamento para trabajar pero antes de
poder hacerlo tienen que llenar muchos
formularios las autoridades están
saturadas por la cantidad de
procedimientos
que
esta es la oficina de administración de
son hojas stéfano españas es uno de los
responsables del lugar cada día tiene
que arreglárselas con los medios que
tiene a su alcance para acoger a los
recién llegados más tenemos llegadas
masivas por lo que hemos podido mejorar
las condiciones de acogida explicó pues
es posible hacerlo cuando se tiene
miranda tanta gente
las restricciones sanitarias ligadas a
la pandemia también han ralentizado los
procedimientos los migrantes pasan en
promedio un mes encerrados en el
campamento sin aire acondicionado y con
temperaturas que rozan los 40 grados a
la sombra para limitar el hacinamiento
el gobierno chipriota está construyendo
un nuevo campamento para alojar a 800
personas en otoño cada mes cientos de
migrantes arriesgan su vida en el
mediterráneo' para cruzar los 160
kilómetros que separan chipre de la
costa libanesa
esta es trípoli la segunda ciudad más
grande del líbano
aquí el 75% de la población vive por
debajo del umbral de la pobreza ante una
crisis económica sin precedentes el
único futuro para los jóvenes es el
exilio ibrahim de 23 años ya intentó
llegar a chipre hace un año pero su
barco tuvo un problema de motor una
patrulla de rescate lo trajo de vuelta a
líbano tras ocho días a la deriva
tengo fotos de antes de la salida las
tomamos en la playa estoy con mi amigo
todavía ha desaparecido
a bordo de la embarcación de ibrahim
murieron 13 pasajeros incluyendo bebés
el primer día que estuvimos atrapados
murió un niño pequeño tuvimos que meter
su cuerpo al agua el segundo día murió
otro niño nacimos 2000 realmente afectó
los ánimos de la gente en el barco
algunas personas se pusieron a llorar a
gritar a pesar del peligro ibrahim
quiere volver a intentar llegar a chipre
con uno de sus amigos cada uno tiene que
reunir el equivalente a 1.500 euros para
pagarles a los traficantes de personas
norman mailer clayton y valle - unique
hicimos solicitudes a las embajadas
oficinas de inmigración pero nadie nos
deja así que acabamos saliendo y
es poco probable que tengan éxito
incluso si llegan a la costa chipriota
corren el riesgo de ser deportados
inmediatamente al líbano los dos países
firmaron un acuerdo de repatriación el
año pasado el mar no es la única ruta
hacia chipre muchos inmigrantes sobre
todo africanos aprovechan la laxitud de
turquía para llegar en avión a través de
estambul a la parte turca de la isla
ocupada militarmente desde 1974 después
sólo les queda cruzar la frontera
ilegalmente
en nicosia un centenar de solicitantes
de asilo acuden cada día a la sede de la
ong cáritas
tienen derecho a 300 dólares de ayudas
estatales al mes pero para recibir estos
subsidios necesitan una dirección que la
ong les proporciona
esto es para usted verdad si es para mí
muchas gracias
no sabía dónde ir este es el único lugar
donde nos ayudan dormí afuera durante un
mes no pueden recibir las ayudas sin
tener una dirección así que utilizan la
nuestra para su correspondencia
la asociación también distribuye
alimentos
hola quieren paz sigo aquí tienen esas
grandes
hay leche para los cereales linas
frijoles
mucha gente que no sabe cocinar prefiere
tomates y caldo de pollo aceites estamos
distribuyendo 10 veces la cantidad de
comida que hace un año
a menudo desempleados los solicitantes
de asilo solo pueden trabajar en
determinados sectores como la
agricultura o la restauración en la
ciudad costera de pafos nos encontramos
con belle que llegó de camerún en 2018
acá estamos en la habitación donde vivo
esa es mi cocina
para ayudar a los que acaban de llegar
creó una página web
están los vínculos para guiar a los
nuevos migrantes
una forma de sentirse útil mientras
espera una decisión sobre su destino las
autoridades chipriotas tardan entre 3 y
5 años en tramitar una solicitud de
asilo
uno no puede visualizar un futuro así
que sobre todo ese futuro borroso lo que
hace que la gente se quede atrapada en
su cabeza y lo que lo estresa a uno
al igual que ver 20.000 personas esperan
que su solicitud sea aceptada siete de
cada diez son rechazados y devueltos a
su país de origen por el gobierno
chipriota